There's a roughly $91 billion
of taxable income underreported
each year.
Our goal is to look
at that type of thing
by looking at how tax
evasion schemes change,
in relation to IRS regulations.
And through this
process, our goal
is to anticipate new iterations
of abusive tax shelters or tax
evasion schemes, what have you.
The government
knows that as soon
as they change the
regulations, they
know there's going to come
up a new tax evasion scheme.
So for them the question
is, can we in some way
be one step ahead,
instead of one step
behind, when it comes
to finding tax evaders?
Our system is
computer-aided law.
And in the past, it's been
looking at past behavior
in trying to look for
similar past behavior.
What they're not
doing is they're not
looking for possible modes
of exploitation that exist
that haven't been seen yet.
So what we're doing,
is essentially
acting as a tax
evader that is working
on the government's side,
almost like an undercover agent.
We're saying, if
we were somebody
that had a very strong
incentive to evade tax,
or to iterate through the
current system of laws
in order to generate tax
savings, what would we do?
Computer science can offer
a lot to law, in a sense,
because you can see the
law says, if you do this,
then this happens,
else this happens.
So it's quite amenable, all
these human regulations,
to try to write them
in as source code.
We're trying to
represent what's written
in the tax law in the software.
One way to describe
it bluntly is
to say we have a
calculator for tax.
We use this calculator to do
simulations, as in saying,
we put in different
inputs of a transaction
and then see what
is our tax output.
Then we can see if
we can optimize it.
So that's where
we're saying, this
is how we find these
transaction sequences that will
pay the least amount of tax.
It's not that far-fetched to
think, as some people say,
the law is code.
And then trying to
figure out how can you,
from a computer
science perspective,
improve this essential
document of civilization as you
can describe the law to be.